está construyendo su futura casa En este
terreno esta parcela de media hectárea
no le costó nada en barbuda la tierra es
de propiedad colectiva no se puede
comprar ni vender
conseguir este terreno solicitándolo al
consejo de barbuda cuando haya
encontrado la parcela que desea rellene
unos formularios y será suya es gratis
los primeros habitantes de barbuda
africanos esclavizados se trajeron
consigo sus tradiciones al producirse La
abolición en 1834 los barbudenses fueron
simplemente olvidados por la corona
británica se organizaron para gestionar
la tierra de forma colectiva como
hicieron sus antepasados en 2007 esto se
consagró por ley con la ley del suelo
estas no fueron tomadas por los
periódicos
como el resto de habitantes de la isla
lo había perdido todo en 2017 tras el
paso del huracán Irma uno de los más
fuertes jamás registrados destruyó gran
parte de barbuda lo escribiría como la
peor noche que alguien pudiera pasar
habiendo experimentado Irma tenías el
aullido del viento es algo que nunca
había oído antes fue aterrador tras el
huracán el gobierno ordenó la evacuación
de todos los habitantes de antigua La
Isla principal de este estado
archipiélago el trauma sigue vivo en la
mente de todos
estas son fotos de la gente después de
la orden de evacuación
durante seis semanas se prohibió a los
barbudenses regresar a sus hogares
la mayoría se fue en barco algunos se
fueron en avión
sin embargo los habitantes solo
esperaban una cosa volver y reconstruir
su Isla desde 2018 el Primer Ministro
Gastón Brown ha intentado introducir la
propiedad privada en barbuda quiere
convertir la isla en un paraíso para los
turistas ricos cuando volvimos a barbuda
la había trabajadores allí esa es una de
las razones no había nadie así que
podían hacer más o menos lo que querían
el grupo estadounidense plh está
construyendo más de 400 Villas de lujo
en el norte de barbuda con lagunas
artificiales y un campo de golf El
activista John Washington quiso
mostrarnos como plh esta privatizando
silenciosamente las playas más bellas de
La Isla este puesto de control está en
medio de una carretera pública Este es
el camino a la playa Denme sus nombres
no podemos dejarlos entrar necesitan un
permiso tras unos minutos de
negociaciones
de seguridad amenazaron con Llamar a la
policía voy a presentar un denuncio
asegúrate de tomar una foto de donde
está su vehículo las acusaciones
solo estamos hablando viene la policía
dejaremos que lo solucionen los
inversionistas extranjeros no pueden
comprar terrenos en la isla el consejo
de barbuda les arrienda una parcela por
un periodo de 50 años pero la autoridad
del Consejo es cuestionada por el
gobierno de antigua lo que el gobierno
intenta decirnos
es que nuestro sistema de propiedad
comunal impide el desarrollo
y que si queremos desarrollar barbuda
tenemos que empezar a permitir las
transacciones de tierras
cuando se abre un mercado así a la
competencia el valor de una propiedad
aumenta hasta el punto de hacerse
inasequible para los habitantes de
barbuda
el actor Robert de Niro compró el
alquiler de este antiguo hotel destruido
por Irma en 2015 se dice que el gobierno
de antigua le ha prometido la propiedad
de las más de 100 hectáreas de terreno
frente a la playa si se revoca la ley
del suelo promesa cumplida en 2018
mientras la población sigue dispersa
tras el huracán Irma la ley del suelo se
cancela desde entonces los barbudenses
han podido recomprar sus tierras al
gobierno por un dólar simbólico sólo
unos 100 habitantes aceptaron este
procedimiento
con una reforma del sistema de tierras
comunitarias cuando la gente no pueda
comprar un terreno
los millonarios comprarán esta playa
pondrán cerca de Tres metros de altura
las barbudenses no podrán comprar aquí
Así que quedaremos excluidos no seremos
nada
desapareceremos tras varios recursos la
renovación de la ley del suelo fue
ratificada por el máximo tribunal de
antigua y barbuda el pasado mes de junio
pero el consejo quiere ahora exponer su
caso ante la Corte Internacional de
Justicia
desde el comienzo de esta crisis
política el gobierno de antigua ha
reducido el presupuesto del Consejo a la
mitad el gobierno está aplicando una
estrategia deliberada para empobrecer a
la población
y se pueden hacer que nos vayamos
eso es lo que quieren Pero eso no va a
suceder
la resistencia se está organizando desde
barbuda
en internet
descubrió otras comunidades que
defienden la propiedad colectiva en todo
el Caribe por mi cuenta sentado aquí
aislado no puedo luchar contra los
multimillonarios pero al establecer
conexiones con otros activistas de
Belice Jamaica Inglaterra y de todo el
mundo somos capaces de encontrar los
recursos para hacer oír nuestras voces
en todo el mundo las comunidades
indígenas de luchan por salvaguardar la
propiedad colectiva en 2016 un informe
de oxfam estimó que 2500 millones de
personas dependían de tierras
comunitarias